et entre tout de suite Sylvain Rousseau
notre envoyé spécial en Ukraine elle
vive Sylvain comment les Ukrainiens
ont-ils perçu se déplacement d'ours sous
l'avant de merlione et Joseph Borel on
sait qu'ils attendent plus de l'Europe
oui effectivement la plupart des gens à
qui nous avons pu en parler ici dans les
rues de le vivre on sait lui
l'initiative malgré tout ils ont salué
se déplacement à Kiev se déplacement
inédit ils ont également salué se
déplacement à bout de chat vous l'avez
vous l'avez rappelé cette cette ville du
nord de Kiev que les forces ukrainiennes
ont retrouvé jonché de cadavres suite à
plusieurs semaines d'occupation russe
mais on en attend bien sûr beaucoup plus
on reconnaît le caractère symbolique de
cette visite notamment au lendemain d'un
nouveau train de sanction pris par
l'Union européenne mais on a ce qu'on
attend ici c'est que l'Europe tape du
point sur la table c'est que l'Europe
décrète un embargo total sur les
importations de pétrole et de gaz russes
ils sont nombreux ici à nous dire que
malgré toutes ces belles paroles et bien
l'Union européenne continue de financer
la Russie dans sa guerre en Ukraine on
le sait les troupes russes regroupent
maintenant à l'est du pays et on annonce
déjà dans les jours à venir peut-être
même dans les heures à venir que ce soit
dans l'est du pays ou dans le sud les
plus violents combats que le sol
européen est connu depuis la Deuxième
Guerre mondiale ici on réclame des armes
et on réclame et bien de de couper les
fonds européens que l'on accuse que l'on
que l'on accuse de continuer en fait à
financer indirectement la guerre en
Ukraine merci